maybe some people don't understand that
when you get harassed at a young age you
might not even put together that that's
what's occurring until later in life
when you're an adult that was one of my
experiences when i was 19 years old i
got a job as an extra in a television
show and the first day i was there the
director who was at least 65 years old
invited me into his trailer for lunch so
i go into his trailer and i know what
you're thinking why did you go into his
trailer
because i was an idiot
i was 19 years old no one had told me
trailers were bad there was a lot of
shit i didn't know i also thought clear
bra straps were clear
i also thought that lady living with my
aunt was her roommate i
also thought guys could be allergic to
latex there was a lot of shit
i hadn't figured out yet
don't blame me
so of course i go into his trailer out
of nowhere he just lunges at me i didn't
understand what's happening because he
was so much older than me i thought he
fell i was like are you okay oh my god
are you passing away what's happening
no idea what to do with that story i
don't remember the guy's name but the
good news is i did accidentally stumble
upon a great way to deal with harassment
at work from a creepy guy just pretend
you think he's having a medical
emergency
next time a guy's like hey sweetie you
want to get a drink later just go oh my
gary thinks he's in my league
i don't know if it's like dementia or
maybe it's a show gary thinks i would
fuck him we've gotta call an ambulance
it's bad